now that we have a general layout in our
minds of how all of the mechanics are
fitting together what I want to do in
this video is discuss a little bit about
why the different actors would do what
they are how they could benefit or get
hurt from this cycle and really why it's
so hard to unwound each of the actors
why it's so hard for them to unwind
themselves from this scenario and where
I finished off this last video I talked
about more cash being in American
pockets because of all of because of
essentially debt being cheap or
government can spend more money lower
taxes and I said no that's more money
for to buy Chinese products but it's in
general more money just for Americans to
spend on each other just to spend on
each other they might buy each other's
houses or buy each other services so in
a lot of ways it does stimulate the
economy for any Keynes Ian's out there
the more you spend that will stimulate
the economy lower taxes for more
conservatives that also can stimulate
the economy and in general debt being
cheaper lower interest rates all of
these things stimulate the economy now
normally when you're stimulating the
economy like this and you have all of
these factors you have the risk of
higher inflation but remember inflation
or at least price inflation is just the
price of all of your goods but notice
we're buying more and more cheaper goods
and interest rates are low so to some
degree this whole cycle also keeps it
looks I guess you could say the the
surface growth that the average American
consumer experienced this looks very
positive and inflation stays slow so we
could also say money back money money to
buy to buy each each other's each
other's services each other's services
now with that said let's think about why
the different actors want to do this so
let's think about it from the Chinese
perspective let's think about it from
the Chinese perspective so if you are
China and you're starting off you are a
real communist country maybe 30 years
ago and then you start to have
market-based reforms and you really want
to enter the developing world but you
don't have the industrial base in the
late 70s or early 80s to really compete
with the German
in the Americas or the end of Japan's
West the Americans in the United States
on their terms so one advantage of
export-led growth export-led growth is
when you're just beginning to develop
maybe you have a more well you have a
less developed Society you have less of
an industrial base so you have export
led growth you can actually build you
actually will encourage investment in
factories that can go and produce things
for the developed world so for for the
developed world and by keeping your
currency low by artificially keeping
your currency low and let me be clear
a lot of which just standard free trade
labor costs are going to be cheaper in a
place like China or India that has a
lower standard of living so there would
be with just straight-up free trade with
no manipulation of currency you would
have things that would move offshore
manufacturing and services and move
offshore but if you supercharge it if
you make it even cheaper to manufacture
to do business in China
it'll just accelerate the investment in
production in China so this export led
growth so let me put it this way let me
put it this way
artificially artificially suppressed
currency and this also happened with
Japan after World War two artificial
suppressed currency and to some degree
we wanted that because we wanted Japan
to become intertwined with the United
States we wanted it to be successful we
saw what happened to Germany after World
War one where it became it was so
economically unsuccessful that it was
very easy for a character like Hitler to
come to power so we learned our lesson
we said you know it's never good for
another country to not have an economic
recovery so we actually did some degree
many people think encourage it in Japan
for anyway you artificially suppress a
currency it makes your exports cheaper
it makes your exports cheaper and which
then encourages more investment in
production at home so then that leads to
more production at home more production
at home and in this case what I'm
talking about home I'm talking about
China or
and and more production at home means
more investment at home more investment
if you're producing more in China you're
gonna have to build more factories more
investment more investment at home and
this means literally more jobs and and
to a large degree capital for the
Chinese people more jobs in capital more
jobs and capital and as you become more
efficient and more as you go down that
development curve you will become more
and more competitive over a whole series
of industries and the idea is once once
your people get developed enough once
your people get developed enough you
will have enough capital at home you
will have enough of a consumer base at
home that some of this extra capacity
can then turn back to your own people
that you can then use these Goods to
sell to your own people to increase
their standard of living so at first you
are building washing machines and
refrigerators for the United States and
Europe and because you're building those
washing machines those are jobs for
Chinese and eventually once they have
enough money once there's a critical
mass of a middle-class Chinese that same
capacity could be used to sell washing
machines and refrigerators to the
Chinese and it was written and it would
raise their standard of living
so manufacturing so it builds a
manufacturing base so let me put it it
builds a manufacturing base and a home
market let me put it that way so this is
kind of from from China's point of view
it looks unambiguously good builds
builds manufacturing base manufacturing
base and and home can stand a domestic
consumer market domestic consumer market
which just means people in China once
they have jobs and they have capital
will be able to buy the goods themselves
and domestic consumer market now where
is the negative here you could imagine
if you are the developed country that is
buying these Goods these arts these they
would be cheap to begin with but now
they're being even there even more
artificially cheap
well you lose your manufacturing base so
if you look at from the US from the US
point of view from the US point of view
you lose you lose the manufacturing base
manufacturing base and it's very clear
that this has been happening whether you
want to point to Japan or in general
we've been losing our manufacturing base
to other countries and some people view
this is a good thing some people say hey
we are further down the development
curve we shouldn't focus on
manufacturing since manufacturing always
tends to go to whoever can do it for the
cheapest price we should focus on
knowledge things whether it's
pharmaceutical industry or the IT
industry so there's maybe maybe an
argument there but the other reason why
this is maybe compelling to the United
States is it's it's lower cost lower
cost lower cost so this looks like a
negative and it is really a negative on
some level but the one I guess you could
call it a superficial positive is lower
cost for for American for American
consumers so if you're not one of the
people who lost their jobs at the
manufacturing plant and you're some
you're you know the great majority of
the rest of Americans it seems like a
good thing things are cheaper for you
it's cheaper to buy clothes for your
kids it's cheaper to buy a car it's
cheaper to buy a refrigerator it's
cheaper to buy an air conditioner now
the problem is when and how does this
end because this whole cycle that we
create I mean it might sound good for
China you know and in theory it sounds
good you you suppress your currency your
goods are cheap more production at home
more investment at home more capital
jobs eventually point that capital point
that investment back at your own home
market and now you are a developed
country seems to make a lot of sense but
it's it's easier said than done in
particular it's not a trivial thing to
make that whole market be as consumptive
or as consumer driven as maybe some of
these developed markets abroad the other
problem is this whole time remember
what's happening
you're just accumulating this mass of in
this case US dollars and you're using it
to go essentially lend to Americans to
lend to the government and
she gets lent to the American people and
the minute that you stop doing it think
about what happens the minute that you
stop not only let's not even talk about
unwinding this let's say the minute you
stop buying dollars your currency will
inflate and the holdings these trillions
of dollars of assets these trillions of
dollars so the minute that you stop
these trillions of dollars of adopt
these trillions of dollars that you've
accumulated will drop in value because
the minute you stop buying dollars the
currency markets will allow the wand to
appreciate the dollar to drop and so
stop buying stop buying leads to drop in
value drop in value and and that's just
if they stop buying if they actually
ever tried to unwind this situation you
would have as soon as they start selling
these that would drop the value of
whether you want to call it the dollar
or the US Treasuries even more and so
everything else they're holding would
drop an even more value so the whole
time in order to keep their currency
propped up they've been buying these
assets they've been buying these dollars
but the very act of unwinding it will I
won't say make it worthless but it will
it will it will make the it will it will
make the value of their holdings go down
dramatically so you have a very hard
situation for the Chinese it's a hard
situation to even get out of and it's
just as hard for the US because if you
think about it a lot of people in the US
would look at this and they'd say hey
this is horrible this is why our
manufacturing base has gone away and it
is partially true and so they would say
hey let the currencies let the
currencies just do it they will let you
know no more artificial distortions no
more manipulation by governments let the
currencies be freely trading but what
would happen then what would happen to
the United States the minute that the
unite that China stops doing this stops
artificially supporting their currency
or even worse the minute they start
unwinding all of this for all of these
dollars that they've accumulated what's
going to happen they're gonna start
selling US Treasuries there's going to
be lower demand for US Treasuries
because not even buying it they might be
selling it interest rates are going to
go up long-term interest long-term
long-term interest would go up in the
United States
now when long-term interest rates goes
up that means that borrowing is harder
that people will want more interest to
lend you money that credit card rates
will go up and in general the entire
United States economy will go down why
are we in this recession right now
because it is harder to borrow that we
were so dependent on cheap debt and when
that got a little less cheap everything
kind of ground to a halt that would be
even worse that would be even worse if
the Chinese stopped buying our debt and
allowed interest rates to go up so we
are kind of locked in this very perverse
cycle where although it looks like the
Chinese are unambiguous lis I guess
benefiting from this they are
accumulating these assets and the minute
that they try to stop accumulating those
assets the value of those assets are
going to go down and even though that
the United States looks like it's
getting their manufacturing base
depleted and that is true it is getting
its manufacturing base depleted because
of this it is keeping interest rates low
and if you're a politician you like that
it makes the overall environment look
superficially positive I'll leave you
there and let you think about this whole
situation for a little bit in the next
video I'll try to do a little bit of
analogy just think about where all of
this might go